les terroristes ont essayé de nous arrêter et cela
m'emmène avec mes amis qui sont ici
aujourd'hui dans notre bus scolaire
[Musique] [
Musique]
elle a été ciblée juste à cause de sa
détermination à aller à l'école et à apprendre
à cibler les extrémistes de Malala a montré ce qu'ils
craignaient le plus un  appelez la veuve
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la faiblesse la peur et le désespoir sont morts la
force le pouvoir et le courage sont nés
[Applaudissements]
quand je reçois ce prix, je sens que
ce n'est pas seulement moi qui reçois savoir ce que c'est
toutes ces filles toute cette jeune
génération qu'elles ont tellement travaillée
dur
[Musique]
d'abord, nous voulions que les hommes fassent quelque chose pour
nous, mais comme ce temps est révolu maintenant, nous
n'allons pas demander aux hommes de changer le monde,
nous allons le faire nous-mêmes, nous allons nous
défendre, nous allons
élever notre  voix et nous allons
changer le monde
il a attrapé une clé Pakistan Doha
jumelles d'agrément pour aujourd'hui d'accord bougez dans les
rues je peux lire les gens je peux parler aux gens
[Musique]
un enfant un enseignant un livre et un
stylo peuvent changer le monde